[音楽]
こんにちは
肇社長です
ちょっと白青ちょっとてーしょんがひっくりというかこうなんと言えばいいのかわかん
ない複雑な心境になっておりますあの
皆さんご存知の通り僕結構不規則な生活してます
一斉もしない人は結構あったり食生活が滅茶苦茶だったリア自炊しないのも原因です
いろいろちょっとユーチューバーになってからですねちょっとぶっ飛んだ生活が続いて
おりまして
ちょっとたる機会がありまして決定機検査をさせていただきました
まあ体に異常がないかという意味も込めてちょっと結果を見てみて最近きたんですけど
も
いやー
まじかとあの僕基本的に健康な人間なんですよ今まで健康診断とかいろいろやって来て
もどれも基本的にこうなんか元気で打ってよりできたんですよ
今回初めてちょっと初めてちょっとまずいぞということをいただきました
なんかこういうがスーツ言ったらちょっと怖いんでなんか店だってマミーの言われたん
で見せないんですけどあえて血液検査の結果
中性脂肪が基準値版よりもかなり高いみたいねぇ surface pro めでとう
じゃないやおめでとうじゃないよ
2選手棒っていうのに僕ととには異常があるみたいです高い子でねあもねすっごい
すっごいすっごい
すごいなんか心当たりがあるんですけども心当たりがありすぎて逆にわかるな2停止
ボートですねまぁ脂質代謝異常
脂肪の代謝かな主質の代謝の異常独自の影響などによって
増減するみたいですやねぇ
[音楽]
心当たりしかは以前中3血液検査たまでやマイリスト化させに言われたら初めてちゃっ
たから割とねちょっと何かちゃんとご飯とかしようって思いましたね
あーなんか色々書いてありますね中性脂肪とは人間の体を動かせエネルギー源である
物質です
高いならいいじゃん米まって高いならいいじゃん要するに彼が動かすエネルギー
値が高いってことでしょ前高エネルギー反応を持ってるところでご飯を食べることに
よって取得歳だし室ですね資質が小腸から吸収されて決定日中に入りてぃ
生命維持活動に使われて言って残ったものが蓄えられたのが2点死亡
字エネルギーた媚びすぎてそれが余っちゃったのかな
その余ったのは中性脂肪らしいです何度なんか
エネルギーあり上がってますみたいなか
力 ariana grande なんて150を超えるとどんくらいだっけ
マックやばいじゃんで待ってやはり待って待って待ってバイ
何かやらなきゃな気がしてきたボク未満医者からの生活習慣や食事等ないような指導が
入るレベルらしいですねまぁいつか来ると思ってましたよ
この食生活多分皆さんが想像している以上にぶっ飛んでますよ
2性脂肪を下げるためには3つのことをしなきゃいけないみたいです1つ
飲酒している場合は禁酒するお酒は3度まないから多分これはしなくていいです2つ
暇運動不足の場合は運動の習慣を始めるそうなんかね
そうよそうやそうやね最近ねなんかやたらと pass get しに行ってるのは実
はちょっと運動不足すぎてやばいなと思う
って最近ちょっとバスケットとかね運動なるべくするように心がけているとこあります
これをクリア
みつめ脂肪や糖質炭水化物を控えた食事をとり小屋名です
いやそういうこと言ってられねーわそういうこと言ってられないんだよね
楽しいかぶつけは控えた方がいいのかもしれないですねでもそんな太ってるわけでも
ないんですよね動かなさすぎなのかもしれない重税脂肪が高いとこな
と僕はどうなるかという話なんですけども知れ脂肪値が高い人たちの粘りが強くどう
ドローになりますそうすると血管が詰まりやすくなる
でなかなか肉一翼を体が頑張って流してるから血管で負担がかかって
でこのまま行くと僕は狭心症心臓に血液が取りにくくなって泣かし見つけられる痛みが
出てきたり
新
銀行速ですねまた脳梗塞ですね脳の結果で血が止まっちゃって神経麻痺になったりする
らしいです
うーん
アーチに来たか播磨までちょっと適当に若さで乗り切ってたところはあるんですけど水
に崩れてきたぞ
ラーメンこんだけ食うような変数ブスラリマー陸線の壁的とかも結構ダメだと思います
がパロディー的にもはいというわけでですねちょっとね血液検査の結果で僕はちょっと
張りとやべえ状況だということに気づいてしまいました
今後
食生活をちゃんとできればいいなと思っていますまず実にしようスイス何か良い嫁を
連れてくるしかない本と結構あの健康診断とかさあ血液検査でちょっとヤバいですって
言われたら結構グッときますよ
ちょっと犯せば機会だから逆に考えたら食べたこのタイミングでラーメンキリスにし
ちゃってかなり正解だったと思いますよまじこれラーメンつ
付けてたら多いがまずポックリ逝ってたでなるべくちょっと油っぽいものとかを控えて
運動を多めでお風もちょっとね極力我慢しながらあさっき組5個食べちゃったぐうたら
生活してるきみ低減者は語るとマジでちゃんとご飯食べた方がいいんじゃ
命がけのじゃあな
[音楽]
me
[拍手]
あっはっ